you look you look like you take care of
yourself that's good I'm gonna have to
take care of that particular part of my
body on Monday
oh you're yeah okay yeah part I didn't
know he made me have a really what part
they haven't told me yet oh really
no just surprised yeah you you know it's
you got to I don't know it's this this
side wait your knee you're going are you
getting your knee replaced yes I am it's
a bad phrase replace you're getting it
resurfaced much gentler way of thinking
about you're just getting your legs
waxed is what you're saying yes that's
all you're doing
are you seriously gonna have an
operation on Monday yeah oh wow yeah
what's wrong with your knee what have
what happened basketball 14 it all got
kind of wonky and then I've had a couple
of operation I wanted to be basketball
players so badly were you a good
basketball player back in the day no I
should have said back in the day cuz
that sounds like yeah sounds like you're
playing and they were like peach baskets
instead an ass two handed said yeah yeah
exactly yeah no but you were when I land
I just loved it passionate I was really
good in high school can't even say high
school prep school small prep school 300
boys any regular high school would have
just cleaned our clocks right so but
anyway loved it passionately my friend
and I went to Stanford and we were
couldn't wait for basketball season and
we stepped out you know on the I I
actually didn't step out on the court
for tryouts I stood right kind of in the
doorway and I went
oh okay this is a different game I mean
everyone was so much better so it was
the same year that Lew Alcindor it was a
freshman at UCLA oh my god yeah
so it was a whole different game okay so
you knew you couldn't do that and is
that when you decided or maybe I'll try
acting there was a depression for about
about six seven months and then I I i
saw this young lady who was serving in
the cafeteria named Beth and I really
wanted to ask her out and she finally
said yes and I we went and had a cup of
coffee halfway through the coffee she
said I have to go audition for something
and I didn't even know what that meant
but I wanted to go with her so I said
kind of coming and she said yes and to
be in the room you had to audition so I
made something up people laughed
I got the smallest part you could get
into play and still be in it but that
was just like it's not basketball but
it's not bad yeah so Beth what if Beth
had been a taxidermist you know thank
you and you're like how this is amazing
it's incredible oh you know that's I'd
be Anchorage Alaska just fortune cookies
your whole life
you